Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode, I talk to Dr. Gurpri Kaur, who is a qualified clinical psychologist and EMDR practitioner. We are talking about so many different things, including
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。在今天的节目中，我采访了Gurpreet Kaur博士，她是一位合格的临床心理学家和EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）治疗师。我们讨论了许多不同的话题，包括
who should be and could be being on social media as a psychologist, but also talking about her faith as a sick and what that means to her how she sees the world and we just generally have conversations about culture faith respect dignity it's such a great episode and i hope you'll find it so useful if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr Marianne Trent and I'm a
作为一名心理学家，谁应该且可以活跃在社交媒体上；我们也谈到了她作为锡克教徒的信仰，以及这对她意味着什么，她如何看待世界。我们还广泛探讨了文化、信仰、尊重和尊严等话题。这是一期非常棒的节目，如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，希望这能成为你的指南。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上获得资格的道路。这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名
qualified clinical psychologist. As you listen to this episode, we are in the middle of clinical application season for the clearing house and also for the educational psychology program too if you would welcome some additional help guidance and support please do check out the free compassionate q a sessions that i run across my socials but there are also replays available that you can listen to or watch on Dr. Marianne Trent on my YouTube channel. Whilst you're there, please do like and subscribe, check a comment in. And if you really like an episode, please do consider sharing it to your network too. So one of the things that we will absolutely need to learn about in any psychology profession and in working with people generally is about faith and culture and how that might show up for them what
合格的临床心理学家。当你收听这期节目时，我们正处于Clearing House（英国临床心理学博士申请系统）的临床申请季，教育心理学项目也是如此。如果你需要额外的帮助、指导和支持，请务必查看我在社交媒体上举办的免费问答环节。此外，你也可以在我的YouTube频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”上收听或观看回放。在观看的同时，请点赞并订阅，留下评论。如果你特别喜欢某一期节目，也请考虑将其分享给你的社交圈。在任何心理学职业中，以及在与人打交道时，我们需要学习的一件事就是关于信仰和文化，以及它们如何体现在人们身上，
barriers and what opportunities that might create for them and I had got chatting with my guest for today on social media and we'd started to have conversations along those lines. I hope you'll find this really interesting, regardless of your own background and your own culture, because there is so much to learn from speaking with others and learning about the way they see the world. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this episode. Hi, I just want to welcome along my guest for today, Dr. Gurpreet Kaur. Gurpreet is a clinical psychologist and an EMDR practitioner. Hi, Gurpreet. Hi, Marianne. Thank you for having me. Thank you very much for being here. We first
这会为他们创造什么样的障碍和机会。我和今天的嘉宾在社交媒体上聊天时，就开始了这方面的探讨。无论你的背景和文化如何，我都希望你会觉得这非常有趣，因为与他人交谈并了解他们看待世界的方式，能让我们学到很多。我期待在节目后与你交流。你好，我想欢迎今天的嘉宾，Gurpreet Kaur博士。Gurpreet是一位临床心理学家和EMDR治疗师。你好，Gurpreet。你好，Marianne。谢谢你邀请我。非常感谢你能来。我们最初
became aware of each other sort of on TikTok and LinkedIn, I think. But I feel like, like yeah you've been on TikTok since I joined TikTok so you've been like an omnipresent face um and that said people should come and follow you because you're doing really well on there much much better than me um but yeah I really like you know the videos that you create and and what you do on this it's lovely to be able to spend some time with you kind of face to face in person thank you so much and likewise I really enjoy watching your content as well and I really think it's important what you're doing trying to talk to people who are at that space where it's probably a little bit scary and predictable and I think it's really important to talk to you through some of the issues that are probably coming up for them thank you so much it's so kind of you to say
是在TikTok和LinkedIn上认识的，我想是这样。我觉得自从我加入TikTok以来，你就一直在那里，你就像是一个无处不在的面孔。人们真的应该来关注你，因为你在那儿做得非常好，比我好得多。我真的很喜欢你创作的视频和你所做的一切。能这样面对面地和你交流真是太好了。非常感谢，我也一样，我很喜欢看你的内容。我认为你所做的事情非常重要，你试图与那些处于可能有点令人害怕和不可预测阶段的人交谈，我认为引导他们解决可能出现的问题非常重要。非常感谢，你这么说真是太客气了。
and just before we went on air we were thinking about actually a change you've heard about on YouTube that means actually it's going to be hopefully easier to find content from qualified professionals because I'm not sure about you but one of my bugbears is when people perhaps have just done a psychology degree or even read a psychology book and then call themselves a psychologist and then sometimes putting out quite dangerous information online no absolutely and i think that's the reason we're out here aren't we trying to get the information across to people but no i think there are changes on youtube where they're having people who are actually accredited qualified practitioners out there and they're somehow labeling them as that as well so i think it's a new update that we can all look out for and hopefully they're somehow labeling them as that as well so i think it's a
在开播前，我们还在讨论YouTube上的一项变动，这意味着未来可能更容易找到合格专业人士的内容。我不确定你是否和我一样，我最反感的一点是，有些人可能只是读了一个心理学学位，甚至只是读了一本心理学书，就自称为心理学家，有时还在网上发布相当危险的信息。绝对是这样。我认为这就是我们在这里的原因，不是吗？我们试图向人们传达正确的信息。我认为YouTube确实有变动，他们正在识别那些真正获得认证的合格从业者，并以某种方式进行标注。我认为这是一个我们都可以期待的新更新，希望他们能
new update that we can all look out for and hopefully they'll do that across most platforms as well because i think that's really really important yeah that would be incredible i think sometimes a tricky thing is especially in journalism as well is that if somebody's got the bare face cheek to call themselves a psychologist then sometimes the qualifications are assumed and even even with a degree and even with a master's sometimes people will think well of course that's enough of course they're qualified but what we know is actually it's only a professional qualification that gets you qualified it's so broad isn't it psychology is such a broad term then the amount of categories
在大多数平台上都这样做，因为我认为这真的非常重要。是的，那将是不可思议的。我认为有时棘手的事情，特别是在新闻业中，如果有人厚着脸皮自称为心理学家，有时人们会默认他们拥有资格。即使拥有学位，甚至硕士学位，有时人们也会认为“当然，这足够了，他们当然是合格的”。但我们知道，实际上只有专业资格才能让你成为合格的从业者。心理学是一个非常广泛的术语，不是吗？
that come underneath that and then how to you know qualify yourself in one of those areas it's it's enormous so no actually you really take that with a pinch of salt when somebody calls themselves a psychologist gets your radar wagging doesn't it like it does that's why i was happy you were on um the was it was it was it was it BBC Five, Channel Five? Doing your work. Brilliant, absolutely brilliant. Get more qualified psychologists out there. Thank you so much.
它涵盖的类别非常多，要在其中一个领域获得资格是非常巨大的工程。所以，当有人自称为心理学家时，你真的要持保留态度。这会让你保持警惕，对吧？确实如此。这就是为什么我很高兴你参加了……是BBC第五台还是第五频道？做你的工作。太棒了，绝对太棒了。让更多合格的心理学家出现在公众视野中。非常感谢。
And to anybody who's like, I don't know what you mean. I can currently be seen. So we're recording as episode two is about to go out on Channel Five in Inheritance Wars, Who Gets the Money? So if you're watching watching or listening to this on replay you should be able to probably watch episode one two three maybe even four by the time it comes up but I think I might be in each episode so thank you so much for your kindness and support so we weren't on here to talk about media we weren't on here to talk about um social media followings and you know proper people being qualified um across these platforms but what we really wanted to think a
对于那些不知道我在说什么的人，我目前正在参与录制。我们录制时，第二集即将要在第五频道播出，节目叫《遗产战争：谁得到了钱？》。所以如果你在观看或收听回放，到节目播出时，你应该能看到第一、二、三集，甚至第四集。我想我可能每一集都在。非常感谢你的善意和支持。我们今天不是来谈论媒体的，也不是来谈论社交媒体粉丝数，或者在这些平台上“真正合格的人”的，我们真正想思考的是
little bit about was you and your career and your faith and how that has been you know interwoven with psychology how that's important for you and and some of that stuff really so could you tell us a little bit about your psychology history and career to date please? It's a really broad question I think where to start um I started you know with the psychology route I suppose at A level because that was my first insight into psychology and what it was went on to study it at degree level and then I went on to do a master's as well and I wasn't really sure about what route I wanted to go down or what I wanted to do as a psychologist until really into my degree where this idea of clinical psychology opened up to me. We're talking about
你和你的职业生涯，以及你的信仰，以及它是如何与心理学交织在一起的，这对你来说为什么很重要。所以，你能告诉我们一些关于你的心理学历史和迄今为止的职业生涯吗？这是一个非常广泛的问题，我想从哪里开始呢？我想我是在A-Level阶段开始接触心理学路线的，那是我的第一次洞察。后来我读了学位，然后又读了硕士。在读学位之前，我并不确定自己想走什么路线，或者作为心理学家想做什么，直到我深入了解了临床心理学这个概念。我们现在谈论的是
the late 1990s now so this is a very long time ago and I didn't really know much about clinical psychology and what it was but it sounded very. So I started to find out a little bit more about it, went down the assistant route and, you know, very luckily I was able to get into a good course. And that's how kind of the process developed for me. But it wasn't a particularly easy one. I certainly wasn't one of those psychologists who just applied and got on the first time or did one assistance post and that was my experience I think it was quite a slog and when I think about it I do think that some of maybe my factors related to my background so parents were working class I didn't have anyone that had gone to university around me I didn't really know what this whole arena of clinical psychology was there was certainly nothing like this that existed at that time so
20世纪90年代末，所以那是很久以前的事了。我当时对临床心理学了解不多，但它听起来很吸引人。所以我开始更多地了解它，走了助理心理学家的路线，非常幸运地进入了一个好的课程。这就是我的过程。但这并不是一条特别容易的路。我肯定不是那种申请一次就成功，或者只做了一份助理工作就入行的心理学家。我认为那是一段相当艰苦的历程。当我回想起来时，我认为这可能与我的背景有关：父母是工人阶级，我周围没有人上过大学，我真的不知道临床心理学这个领域是什么，当时肯定没有像现在这样的资源，所以
it was hard to connect with people and find out about it so it was really a process of just learning and figuring it out along the way and I ended up kind of getting into clinical psychology that way amazing and what's your current specialism where do you work what do you do so I worked in the NHS from 2001 that was pre my qualification um really as assistant psychologist and then all the way through up until around I'd say 2018 where I started to sidestep into private practice and that's really just because mother of three kids you know trying to balance it all the constraints of the NHS as well and feeling a little bit like I couldn't thrive there so I started to sidestep into private practice in Surrey where I'm based and I actually work online so I can see people from wherever and I think
很难与人建立联系并了解它。所以这真的是一个在过程中学习和摸索的过程，我就是这样进入临床心理学的。太棒了。你目前的专长是什么？你在哪里工作？你做什么？我从2001年开始在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作，那是在我获得资格之前，主要是作为助理心理学家，一直到2018年左右，我开始转向私人执业。这主要是因为作为三个孩子的母亲，要平衡一切，还要面对NHS的限制，感觉自己无法在那里茁壮成长。所以我开始在萨里（Surrey）转向私人执业，我现在就在那里。我实际上是在线工作的，所以我可以接待来自各地的人。我认为
throughout my career I've I always felt that some of the models in the way we were taught particularly during training were were great and I think they've all got their you know positive aspects to them but some were quite limiting um and I find that I found that personally there was a lot more that needed to be spoken about with certain clients than was than we were being courage encouraged to do maybe on the course so I found my interest really in trauma and I felt that that perspective enabled me to get a real good sense of a person's struggles and create a great formulation about what they were experiencing and why they were struggling and so that's the area that I've started to well
在我的整个职业生涯中，我一直觉得我们在培训期间学到的一些模型非常棒，它们都有积极的一面，但有些也相当局限。我个人发现，与某些客户需要讨论的内容，比课程中鼓励我们讨论的要多得多。所以我发现自己对创伤产生了兴趣，我觉得这个视角使我能够真正了解一个人的挣扎，并对他们正在经历的事情以及他们为什么挣扎做出很好的构思。所以这就是我开始……
more recently I've really started to specialize and focus in that so that's why I went on to study the EMDR became a practitioner in that and quite interestingly how I'm seeing trauma show up for people especially from minority backgrounds is as imposter syndrome and so that's they're the kind of two areas that I'm very, very interested in. So the early experiences people have, how it impacts them growing up, and then the impact of that as an adult, in that sense of that imposter feeling that they have. So quite diverse background, but I'm very specialist now. Okay. And I always try to save people a Google in case they don't know what something is.
最近我真正开始专攻和关注的领域。这就是我学习EMDR并成为该领域从业者的原因。有趣的是，我看到创伤在少数族裔背景的人身上表现为“冒名顶替综合征”。所以这是我非常非常感兴趣的两个领域：人们早期的经历，它如何影响他们的成长，以及作为成年人，这种影响如何转化为他们那种“冒名顶替”的感觉。所以背景相当多元，但我现在非常专业。好的。我总是尽量帮人们省去谷歌搜索的麻烦，以防他们不知道某个术语。
Could you tell us a bit more about what imposter syndrome is and how it might show up for people? So imposter syndrome is a term that was developed in 1978. It was actually by psychologists who found that there was a group of women who despite their high achievements, despite how good they were at everything, they just felt like they were not good enough. They felt like their success was not their own to own. And they felt like their strengths were just, you know, they kind of put themselves down a little bit. And so that's how it is today. It's people who are perfectionists. It's people who fear failure. It's people who have that constant need to feel like they have to do do better despite putting a lot of work into it and maybe sometimes overwork with that as well but it's inherently that sense of not being good enough and I think that shows up for a lot of people and unfortunately I think a lot of the
你能多告诉我们一些关于什么是“冒名顶替综合征”以及它如何表现出来吗？“冒名顶替综合征”是一个在1978年提出的术语。它实际上是由心理学家提出的，他们发现有一群女性，尽管她们成就很高，尽管她们在各方面都很出色，但她们就是觉得不够好。她们觉得自己的成功不是自己应得的。她们觉得自己的优势……她们有点看轻自己。这就是今天的定义。它是指那些完美主义者，那些害怕失败的人，那些总是觉得尽管付出了很多努力，甚至有时过度工作，但仍需要做得更好的人。但它本质上是一种“不够好”的感觉。我认为这在很多人身上都有体现，不幸的是，我认为很多
systems that people work in and the organizations actually encourage that sense of overwork overperform be a perfectionist because that's what we want and that will get you the rewards. So it's a system, systemic issue, I think, as well as a personal one, unfortunately. Yeah, I don't know what your experience of parenting children in modern schools is, but it very much for me seems that they're trying to give more attention to everybody regardless of ability levels and trying to make sure that everybody is not always the same children that get you know certificates and awards and praise and it's not you know it's not just the children that are struggling that are getting the attention so even during so I think we've got our youngest children in the same school year, but the SATs happened last year and they were giving everybody extra tuition in our school year so that everybody could do better rather than just, you know, just specific children. I think there's obviously a COVID fallout here in terms of our children and what they've been through for their early education.
人们工作的系统和组织实际上鼓励这种过度工作、过度表现、追求完美的感觉，因为这就是我们想要的，这会给你带来回报。所以，我认为这是一个系统性问题，也是一个个人问题。是的，我不知道你作为现代学校家长的经历如何，但对我来说，他们似乎确实在试图给予每个人更多的关注，无论能力水平如何，并试图确保不是总是同样的孩子获得证书、奖励和表扬。不仅仅是那些挣扎的孩子得到关注。所以，即使在……我想我们最小的孩子在同一个年级，但去年进行了SAT考试，他们在我们的年级给每个人都提供了额外的辅导，这样每个人都能做得更好，而不是只针对特定的孩子。我认为这里显然有新冠疫情对我们孩子早期教育影响的后果。
But for me, it feels, because I was a governor for two years as well, a parent governor, it feels like they're really trying to do what they can to make everybody feel worthwhile. worthwhile and you know what we go through working with people with trauma is that you know sometimes school might be a safe place and they try to really it's probably school dependent but really holistically we meet the needs of a child and so I do hope that that in time things may you know even our emotional literacy and our ability to talk about our feelings may be better than for my age group I think and certainly the way we raise our boys you know I think schools are being much more mindful and certainly with all the gender stuff that's going on currently very much more mindful about things not just being for boys and not just being for girls and that boys don't need to be tough and not cry and brave and yeah I think it's very interesting having even you know I'm 42 even reflecting on the way that I was schooled and what my experience of watching
但对我来说，因为我也做了两年的校董，家长校董，感觉他们真的在尽力让每个人都感到有价值。你知道，我们在与创伤患者工作时，有时学校可能是一个安全的地方，他们真的试图……这可能取决于学校，但从整体上讲，我们满足孩子的需求。所以我确实希望随着时间的推移，事情可能会……甚至我们的情感素养和谈论感受的能力可能会比我这一代人更好。我认为，当然，我们抚养男孩的方式，我认为学校正变得更加谨慎，当然，随着目前所有关于性别的事情，在事情不仅仅是为男孩准备的，也不仅仅是为女孩准备的方面，更加谨慎。男孩不需要变得强硬、不哭泣、勇敢。是的，我认为即使我42岁了，反思我受教育的方式，以及我看着
others be schooled was to now what's your take on all of that Capri? Oh it's all very different now and I do think there is much more emphasis on the child's well-being. You're seeing a lot more focus on that. My concern is that I think it's great in that it's sowing seeds, sowing seeds that maybe our generation didn't have in our school experience. I do get concerned, actually, if it's not mirrored at home or if children don't experience that sense of safety or that kind of language around being able to express themselves or emotional vulnerability it's still going to create a disparity isn't it between what someone's hearing at school and what someone's experiencing at home so unfortunately I just think it's more of a systemic issue I think
别人受教育的经历，到现在，这非常有趣。你对此有什么看法，Gurpreet？哦，现在完全不同了。我确实认为对孩子幸福感的重视程度更高了。你看到了更多的关注。我的担忧是，我认为它在播下种子方面很棒，播下了我们这一代人在学校经历中可能没有的种子。我确实感到担忧，如果这在家里没有得到呼应，或者如果孩子们没有体验到那种安全感，或者那种能够表达自己或情感脆弱的语言，这仍然会造成差异，不是吗？在一个人在学校听到的和在家里经历的之间。所以不幸的是，我只是认为这更多是一个系统性问题。我认为
the schools are doing what they can do which is great but again it's only a very small part essentially I know when we're at school we feel like it's forever but it really is such a small part of a person's lifetime isn't it and then if then they fall into a career that actually demands very very high standards of them for them to be just okay or on par with other people I think that's where the damage can happen because it can really fuel some of those earlier negative core beliefs if they've been picked up along the way in yeah in situations that may be a bit more adverse and so yeah no I think schools are doing what they can I just think there's a lot more that can be done and I do think that there's more opportunity for people to learn with for example us you know therapists on social media there's a lot more information out there in terms
学校正在尽其所能，这很好，但同样，这本质上只是很小的一部分。我知道当我们在学校时，我们觉得那是永远，但它确实是一个人一生中很小的一部分，不是吗？然后如果他们进入了一个实际上要求他们有非常非常高标准的职业，让他们仅仅是“还可以”或与其他人在同一水平，我认为这就是伤害可能发生的地方，因为它真的会助长一些早期的负面核心信念，如果这些信念是在……在可能更不利的情况下被拾起的话。所以是的，我认为学校正在尽其所能，我只是认为还有很多事情可以做。而且我确实认为人们有更多的机会学习，例如我们这些在社交媒体上的治疗师。在
of mental health mental well-being mindset work all of this stuff and I think companies are getting a lot more into this as well so they're recruiting a lot more people to come and talk but I think it's that part where people are giving themselves the permission to think that actually this applies to me. Let me sit and figure out my beliefs. Let me think about actually what are any barriers that I have? What are my blocks? What are my pain points that I need to probably do some work on? So it's kind of a mixed bag, isn't it? Yeah, I think what you're describing so nicely is the work that you and Dr. Claire Plumley and of course, Dr. Julie Smith have done is, is de-shaming, you know, what people are going through and knowing that actually, it's not my fault, the way I'm feeling and you know,
心理健康、心理幸福感、思维方式工作等方面，有很多信息。我认为公司也越来越多地参与其中，所以他们招募了更多的人来谈论这些。但我认为，关键在于人们是否给自己许可去思考：“实际上，这适用于我。让我坐下来弄清楚我的信念。让我思考一下，我有什么障碍吗？我的阻碍是什么？我需要处理的痛点是什么？”所以这有点像是一个混合体，不是吗？是的，我认为你描述得非常好，你、Claire Plumley博士，当然还有Julie Smith博士所做的工作，就是“去羞耻化”，你知道，人们正在经历的事情，并知道实际上，我现在的感受不是我的错，而且你知道，
the things that can be done and I don't deserve to suffer, I don't need to suffer. And to have some confidence that that can change that's really powerful that's absolutely it there's a really nice hashtag that's you make sense on uh instagram I can't remember the therapist that had that but I thought that that's it because we're told so often we're made to feel so often that there's something wrong with us that because we don't fit in it's because us, or because we can't perform in the same way, it's because of us. And I think that's it. If you can understand your life story, your life circumstances, the situation that you were born in, the cards you've been dealt with, then it just gives you so much more grounding in who you are and acceptance, hopefully,
可以做些什么，我不应该受苦，我不需要受苦。并且有信心这种状况是可以改变的，这非常强大。绝对是这样。Instagram上有一个很好的标签叫“你是有道理的”（you make sense），我不记得是哪位治疗师提出的，但我认为这就是重点。因为我们经常被告知，我们经常被弄得觉得我们有什么问题，因为我们不合群，是因为我们自己，或者因为我们不能以同样的方式表现，是因为我们自己。我认为就是这样。如果你能理解你的人生故事、你的人生境遇、你出生的环境、你所拿到的牌，那么它就会让你对自己是谁有更多的立足点和接纳，希望
to move forward from that point, rather than some version of yourself that you think should exist based on some external definition of what a person like you should be like I think it's just a marrying up of all those things really isn't it it is and I honestly I just I just feel like we've got the best job in the world like I just I love how I've been able to learn and grow and develop and I remember when I was in my probably mid-20s and I was in a job working for local council and I just thought oh this is it I'm like I'm not going to make any more friends I'm not going to have any more friends I'm not gonna have any more like big opportunities oh this is it oh and then soon after that I then got a paid assistant post and had a big expansion of friends and then you know regular supervision and being able to grow and learn and shape and develop and all of the
能从那个点向前迈进，而不是成为某种你认为应该存在的、基于外部定义的“像你这样的人应该是什么样”的自我版本。我认为这只是所有这些事情的结合，不是吗？确实是。老实说，我真的觉得我们拥有世界上最好的工作。我喜欢我能够学习、成长和发展的方式。我记得我大概20多岁的时候，在地方议会工作，我当时想：“哦，就是这样了，我不会再交到新朋友了，我不会再有大的机会了，哦，就是这样。”然后在那之后不久，我就得到了一份带薪助理职位，朋友群扩大了，然后你知道，有定期的督导，能够成长、学习、塑造和发展。我旅程中所有的
supervisors I've had along my journey have really helped have a look at myself and my impact on my clients and you know I don't know about you but every supervision session I have I learn something more about myself or ways to help clients and it's like it's so invigorating it's not stagnating at all it's an amazing career and actually I think that that whole personal professional development bit that we've we're told from day one is so crucial it's so very very important and giving yourself the permission to actually be able to learn this stuff for you you know not just learn for your clients or not just learn because your supervisor suggested that this is important for you to learn and pass all the course requirements I think just to be able to benefit from that ourselves and to take that on board I think
督导都真的帮助我审视了自己以及我对客户的影响。你知道，我不知道你怎么样，但我每次督导会议都能学到更多关于我自己的东西，或者帮助客户的方法。这太令人振奋了，一点也不停滞。这是一个了不起的职业。实际上，我认为我们从第一天就被告知的整个个人和专业发展部分是如此关键。这非常非常重要，给自己许可去真正学习这些东西，不仅仅是为了你的客户，也不仅仅是因为你的督导建议这对你很重要，或者为了通过所有课程要求。我认为仅仅能够从中受益并将其吸收，我认为
that's a really crucial part and actually that part I feel really sits well with myself as a Sikh as a person who comes from Sikhi which is a religion that it's a way of life that is fairly young compared to some of the other major religions, in that the word Sikh actually means learner. And so to be able to give myself that permission with my job and what I do, to be able to actually just learn and soak up all of this information for myself, to keep learning and to keep understanding what are the new models what are the new theories I love it it's it's it's a bit strange sometimes I don't know if you feel this but it's quite surreal to be able to have that
这是一个非常关键的部分。实际上，我觉得这部分与我作为一名锡克教徒非常契合。作为一个来自锡克教（Sikhi）的人，这是一种生活方式，与一些其他主要宗教相比相当年轻。锡克（Sikh）这个词实际上意味着“学习者”。所以，能够给我在工作中和所做的事情中这种许可，能够真正地学习并吸收所有这些信息，不断学习并不断理解什么是新的模型，什么是新的理论，我喜欢它。这有时有点奇怪，我不知道你是否有这种感觉，但能够拥有这种
permission to be able to do that with my job it's it's a it's a privilege it really is it is and I'm glad you brought up your religion there because I was wondering how that has impacted on you and the way that you see the world and your clients. And I wonder if I've made a horrendous faux pas all of my life because you've just pronounced it sick and I've always called it Sikh and Sikhism. Have I been doing that wrong all the time? I don't think it's the right or wrong. I'm not here to tell anybody you know i'm just so glad that you're aware of it because it's actually one of the fifth biggest religions i like if you like but it's fair there's not much known about it i think so you can we say sick because that's the way we pronounce it that's just our our way of verbalizing it seek is fine but if you would like to go forward saying sick you know that's great it comes from gorsik because our religion is based on the idea that
许可去做这件事，这是一种特权，真的是这样。确实是。我很高兴你提到了你的宗教，因为我一直在想它是如何影响你、你看待世界的方式以及你的客户的。我想知道我这一辈子是不是犯了一个可怕的失礼，因为你刚才把它读作“Sick”，而我一直把它读作“Sikh”和“Sikhism”。我一直都读错了吗？我不认为有什么对错。我不是来告诉任何人什么的，你知道，我只是很高兴你意识到它，因为它是第五大宗教，如果你愿意的话。但关于它的了解并不多。所以，我们可以说“Sick”，因为那是我们的发音方式，那只是我们口头表达的方式。“Seek”也可以，但如果你想继续说“Sick”，你知道，那很好。它来自“Gursikh”，因为我们的宗教基于这样一个理念：
we had some gurus you know showing us the way like we had 10 gurus and so if we are following this way in this faith then we become a sick of them so we become a gursik um but no don't think that you've made some big error or anything like that it's it's a learning process and again all we can do is just keep learning isn't it about each other's cultures religions perspectives and I think it's just nice to be able to bring this in so casually actually into this conversation because there have been parts I suppose of my career where I've not been so comfortable to actually bring in who I am um so it's just nice to be at a point where this is a fluid thing that can now come into conversations. Yeah. And, you know, what I love about our profession as well is that we get a chance to work with people from, you know, either as colleagues or clients or both from such a variety of backgrounds.
我们有一些上师（Gurus）向我们展示道路，我们有10位上师。所以如果我们遵循这条道路和这种信仰，我们就成为他们的“Sikh”，所以我们成为“Gursikh”。但不要认为你犯了什么大错。这是一个学习的过程，同样，我们能做的就是不断学习，不是吗？关于彼此的文化、宗教、观点。我认为能够如此随意地将这一点带入对话真是太好了，因为在我的职业生涯中，确实有一些时候我不太舒服去真正带入我是谁。所以，能够达到这一点，即这成为一个可以自然融入对话的流动事物，真是太好了。是的。而且，你知道，我喜欢我们职业的一点是，我们有机会与来自各种背景的人一起工作，无论是作为同事还是客户，或者两者兼有。
I remember when I just started in a heart of Birmingham service when I was just qualified and I was given a load of little books that are given to children about different religions and the first one I picked up was Rastafarianism and actually until then until the age of what was I 30 29 30 or something like I think I might have been 30 I hadn't realized Rastafarianism was actually a religion I just thought it was like a sort of Bob Marley way of being I didn't you know I didn't realize that that was actually a religion a way of life and you know I think it's incredible isn't it like what we can learn and how we can understand the way that others might see the world. Yeah absolutely that's a crucial part of what we do and I think as an
我记得我刚在伯明翰中心服务处工作时，刚获得资格，我得到了一堆给孩子们看的关于不同宗教的小书。我拿起的第一个是拉斯塔法里教（Rastafarianism）。实际上，在那之前，直到我30岁左右，我可能30岁了，我还没意识到拉斯塔法里教实际上是一种宗教。我只是以为它是一种鲍勃·马利（Bob Marley）式的生活方式。我不知道那实际上是一种宗教，一种生活方式。你知道，我认为这令人难以置信，不是吗？我们可以学到什么，以及我们如何理解他人看待世界的方式。是的，绝对是。这是我们所做工作的关键部分。我认为作为一名
effective clinical psychologist I think that's the bit that makes the difference so I think there's there's a tendency when we're very early on in our career very early on in our training to just try to do what we're told in terms of you know meet those assessment requirements think about the intervention think about the model theory and all of that but I think it's so important to really sit with a person's culture whatever that is and however that shows up for them, rather than our definition of what that should be for them. And I think that's very, very powerful. And that's the bit that can really create that relationship and that therapeutic bond that can be very, very healing for a person. I can't remember the name of the paper or actually much about it, but I remember quite early on in our training, we were told that the most important part of a successful therapeutic intervention is actually based on the relationship between you and the therapist rather than the model, rather than the theory or anything else that you do.
有效的临床心理学家，我认为这正是产生差异的地方。我认为在职业生涯早期，在培训早期，有一种倾向，就是试图按照被告知的那样去做，即满足那些评估要求，思考干预措施，思考模型理论等等。但我认为，真正坐下来理解一个人的文化，无论那是什么，无论它如何体现在他们身上，而不是我们对那应该是什么的定义，是非常重要的。我认为这非常非常强大。这就是能够真正建立那种关系和治疗纽带的部分，这对一个人来说是非常非常有疗愈作用的。我不记得那篇论文的名字，或者关于它的细节，但我记得在培训早期，我们被告知，成功的治疗干预最重要的部分实际上是基于你和治疗师之间的关系，而不是模型，而不是理论，也不是你做的任何其他事情。
And I thought that's really powerful. Why is that not emphasised more? I wonder if that's Rogers. Was it Carl Rogers and his kind of relationship-y type stuff? He's certainly spoken about that, but it might not have been the one that you're thinking of. I think it was a specific paper and they did like a diagram. I should try and find what that was.
我觉得这非常强大。为什么这一点没有被更多地强调？我想知道那是不是罗杰斯（Rogers）。是卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers）和他的那种关系型的东西吗？他肯定谈到过这一点，但这可能不是你正在想的那篇。我认为那是一篇特定的论文，他们做了一个图表。我应该试着找出那是什么。
But it was quite a large percentage of it was actually based on the therapeutic relationship, which is process-based, isn't it? And I think that can be emphasised by actually sitting with and trying to understand who is this person in front of me what's their relationship to their world their environment their culture their spirituality their race everything that actually people probably don't ask them much about that probably they may not sit with much that maybe they're they're walking around just with, you know, their, I suppose, assumed versions of what they think it is, rather than sitting with it and actually thinking about it separately from a different perspective. So I think that's really, really powerful.
但其中很大一部分实际上是基于治疗关系，这是过程导向的，不是吗？我认为这可以通过坐下来并试图理解“坐在我面前的这个人是谁”来强调。他们与世界、环境、文化、灵性、种族的关系是什么？实际上人们可能不会问他们太多关于这些的问题，可能他们不会坐下来思考太多，可能他们只是带着他们假设的、他们认为的版本走来走去，而不是坐下来，从不同的角度独立地思考它。所以我认为这真的非常非常强大。
So, you know, I think that anyone who is sick who's listening to this will feel excited that we're having this conversation, but probably the majority of people listening will be thinking, well, what is sick who's listening to this will feel excited that we're having this conversation but probably the majority of people listening will be thinking well what is sickism and how might my clients who are sick um be viewing the world or what you know what what cultural constraints and you know opportunities for them to flourish have they got and whilst we can't pigeonhole people sometimes it's useful to even you know even things like for judoism um you know you might not want to make plans with them on a friday evening because they might have plans you know what might we be able to learn or think about how to be inclusive and understand someone who's who's sick so i think it's a tough question to answer in a way because
所以，你知道，我认为任何收听此节目的锡克教徒都会因为我们正在进行这次对话而感到兴奋，但可能大多数听众会想：“什么是锡克教，我的锡克教客户可能如何看待世界，或者他们有什么文化限制和繁荣的机会？”虽然我们不能把人归类，但有时即使是像犹太教那样的事情，你可能不想在周五晚上和他们做计划，因为他们可能有安排。我们能学到什么，或者思考如何包容并理解一个锡克教徒？所以我认为这是一个很难回答的问题，因为
there are i don't think there are set things that might necessarily like you could refer to in that way to say i'll connect with this or connect that but actually one example that's coming to mind is I had a trainee on my course ask me because he was feeling quite a block with an elderly sick gentleman he was working with who had depression and we spoke about something that's quite important in our faith which is which is community and actually connect finding a way to connect with his sangath again at his local gudora and which is the place of worship and actually such a simple intervention for that elderly Sikh man to hear this young white British you know professional to suggest
我不认为有什么固定的东西你可以参考，说“我会连接这个或那个”。但实际上，我脑海中浮现的一个例子是，我课程中的一名学员问我，因为他在与一位患有抑郁症的老年锡克教绅士工作时感到相当受阻。我们谈到了我们信仰中相当重要的一点，即社区，以及寻找一种方式与他在当地锡克庙（Gurdwara）的“Sangath”（社区）重新建立联系。锡克庙是礼拜场所。实际上，对于那位老年锡克教徒来说，听到这个年轻的白人英国专业人士建议
actually have you got any sangath can you connect with your sangath it was quite transforming for him apparently that was that in itself was such a small thing, but it had a powerful impact on him, because it somehow reminded him of actually a key tenet, which is actually we do need Sangha around us, we do need Sangha who are inspiring, we do need people who can uplift us, and we do need to feel that sense of connection as human beings, so I think that's really really important spirituality is obviously a very very important part of Sikhi and that's going to look different to everybody not coming in with any assumptions I think about what that looks like for people is going to be an important aspect but it can look like actually you know some kind of meditation some kind of prayer
“你有Sangath吗？你能与你的Sangath联系吗？”这对他来说相当具有变革性。显然，这本身是一件很小的事情，但它对他产生了强大的影响，因为它以某种方式提醒了他一个关键原则，即我们确实需要周围有Sangath，我们需要能激励我们的Sangath，我们需要能提升我们的人，我们需要作为人类感受到那种联系。所以我认为这非常非常重要。灵性显然是锡克教非常非常重要的一部分，这对每个人来说看起来都不同。我认为不带任何假设地进入，关于这对人们来说是什么样子，将是一个重要的方面。但它看起来可能实际上是某种冥想，某种祈祷，
some kind of singing through what we call gitan or listening to keep them which is religious songs and i think that's that can be quite an important discussion to have with people because i think with any faith or with any practice there can be some quite heavy connotations about what they should be doing and what they should be practicing or how they should be doing that and that in itself can become quite burdensome for people so I think trying to allow a person to connect with any aspect in a way that feels more meaningful to them is the discussion that probably needs to be had with that person rather than what they should be doing it really comes back to that CBT approach doesn't it try to take away any of the heaviness, to try to neutralise the thoughts and try to
某种通过我们称之为“Kirtan”的歌唱，或者聆听“Kirtan”，也就是宗教歌曲。我认为这可以是一个与人们进行的重要讨论，因为我认为对于任何信仰或任何实践，关于他们应该做什么，他们应该如何实践，或者他们应该如何做，可能会有一些相当沉重的内涵。这本身对人们来说可能变得相当沉重。所以我认为，试图让一个人以一种对他们来说更有意义的方式与任何方面建立联系，是可能需要与那个人进行的讨论，而不是他们“应该”做什么。这真的回到了CBT（认知行为疗法）的方法，不是吗？试图消除任何沉重感，试图中和思想，并试图
really reconnect your values to what your understanding of your practice is. So I think that's essentially really, really an important part of it. Thank you. And do all six cover their hair? That might sound like a really basic question, but I've certainly got friends who don't um and but you but you you do could you guide us through a little bit along that those lines please but absolutely not you'll get people who who cut their hair who shave their kind of beards because traditional Sikh men keep their beards and we keep our hair that's really an important part of Sikhi um but again it depends on that person's connection to their religion so I think that's an important thing to talk about.
真正将你的价值观与你对实践的理解重新连接起来。所以我认为这本质上是非常非常重要的一部分。谢谢。所有的锡克教徒都遮盖头发吗？这听起来可能是一个非常基本的问题，但我确实有不遮盖的朋友，但你遮盖了。你能引导我们了解一下这方面的情况吗？绝对不是。你会遇到剪头发、刮胡子的人，因为传统的锡克教男性留胡子，我们留头发，这是锡克教非常重要的一部分。但同样，这取决于那个人与他们宗教的联系。所以我认为这是一个重要的讨论话题。
Just because somebody looks a certain way, we cannot make any inference about what their level of connection to their religion is or their faith or their way of life. So it always comes back to that one to one discussion with that person in terms of what meaning it has to them. Absolutely. It's how does that matter to you? How does that show up for you and thinking about the messages that you've been given from your own family and I know when I was working in heart of Birmingham there was lots of conflict actually with young people who had been raised who'd been born in Birmingham but their their parents were first you know they they were born elsewhere in different countries and there was lots of conflict between kind of the east meets west of of the usually
仅仅因为某人看起来像某种样子，我们不能对他们与宗教、信仰或生活方式的联系程度做出任何推断。所以它总是回到与那个人的“一对一”讨论，关于它对他们有什么意义。绝对是。它是“这对你有什么意义？它如何体现在你身上？”并思考你从自己家庭中收到的信息。我知道我在伯明翰中心工作时，与那些在伯明翰出生长大，但父母是第一代移民，出生在其他国家，在东西方文化碰撞中长大的年轻人之间，确实有很多冲突。
young women wanting to grow up being western but not wanting to alienate and upset their family and it's really really tricky road to to try and travel I think that's I think that's going to be a conflict for anybody really isn't it coming from a different culture where their parents may be our first generation and they're born second generation here and it's thinking about how to maneuver that I think a lot of the blocks that I see actually when I'm thinking about some of the South Asian clients I see because I think it is a really broad category of people who probably struggle with this there always seems to be some block in communication in terms of actually what maybe the expectations are and the why and then connecting to the value is this important for you
年轻女性想要成长为西方人，但又不想疏远和惹恼家人，我认为这真的是一条非常非常棘手的路。我认为对于任何来自不同文化背景的人来说，这都是一种冲突，不是吗？他们的父母可能是第一代移民，而他们是出生在这里的第二代，这需要思考如何处理这种关系。我认为当我想到我所接触的一些南亚客户时，我确实看到了很多障碍，因为我认为这是一个非常广泛的人群，他们可能都在为此挣扎。在沟通方面似乎总是存在某种障碍，比如期望到底是什么，为什么会有这些期望，以及将这些期望与价值观联系起来，这对你来说重要吗？
and if it isn't why is it important for you So there seems to be a very big mismatch between parents, the generation that came here, what they understand about what's important versus children here. And sometimes that's because actually the values may be not being lived. You know, if children don't see the adults actually living out their values, there will be a sense of a disconnect that could be it could be due to numerous reasons couldn't it but I think parents coming here it was just such a stressful time you know to come here and you know manual workers just working as many hours as they can to to give us that security um and I think that again that can cause some sense of kind of disconnection as well can't it there's that sense of it's it's not neglect but it's almost like an intentional neglect there isn't there and so a child is going to go looking elsewhere probably and they're going to go towards their friends they're going to go towards their
如果这不重要，那为什么它对你很重要？所以，父母（来到这里的那一代）对什么是重要的理解，与这里的孩子之间似乎存在巨大的错位。有时这是因为价值观实际上并没有被践行。你知道，如果孩子们没有看到成年人真正践行他们的价值观，就会产生一种脱节感。这可能是由于多种原因造成的，不是吗？但我认为父母来到这里时，那真是一段压力很大的时期，你知道，来到这里，做体力劳动，尽可能多地工作，为了给我们提供那种安全感。嗯，我认为这也会导致某种程度的脱节，不是吗？那不是忽视，但几乎就像是一种故意的忽视，不是吗？所以孩子可能会去别处寻找，他们会转向他们的朋友，他们会转向他们的
school they're going to go towards kind of other sources that are more interesting for them and so that disconnect can unfortunately start happening and i think think the repair for that or the way to try to overcome that is what we're trying to do as parents nowadays, I suppose, in our generation is talk, talk, talk, explain, converse, have conversations, contemplate, which, again, is a very important part of Sikhi is this idea of vijar, where you're able to have discussions around all these concepts around all our experiences around the difficulties and sometimes unfortunately I think that is the bit that causes the block when that doesn't happen and then you just you're kind of clashing heads yeah I absolutely agree um and I really want to make sure that that we're getting all of these terms right and so what I'm
学校，他们会转向其他对他们来说更有趣的来源，所以这种脱节不幸地开始发生。我认为弥补这一点，或者说我们作为当今这一代的父母试图克服这一点的方法，就是交谈、交谈、再交谈，解释、交流、对话、沉思。这再次成为锡克教的一个非常重要的部分，即“vijar”（思考/讨论）的概念，在这里你能够围绕所有这些概念、我们所有的经历、困难进行讨论。有时不幸的是，我认为当这种情况没有发生时，就会导致障碍，然后你们就只是在发生冲突。是的，我完全同意。嗯，我真的想确保我们把所有这些术语都弄对，所以我
going to do is once we've got the transcript for this show is I'm going to send the little pieces with with words that are not native to me to you to make sure that we're spelling them right um and perhaps we'll on socials that week we'll get like a little a little thing going with what what it means and what it is and how you might hear that and represent you know recognize that when it thank you that's really powerful even that in itself that's a really respectful thing for you to do so I appreciate that thank you I just I'm always keen to learn and you know whenever I've worked with people whose first language is not English and we've had to have an interpreter I've tried to get them to
打算做的是，一旦我们有了这个节目的文字记录，我就会把那些对我来说不是母语的词汇的小片段发给你，以确保我们拼写正确。嗯，也许那一周我们会在社交媒体上发布一个小内容，说明它是什么意思，它是什么，你可能会如何听到它，并认识到它。谢谢你，这真的很强大，即使是这一点本身，这也是你做的一件非常尊重人的事情，所以我很感激，谢谢你。我只是，我总是渴望学习，你知道，每当我与母语不是英语的人一起工作，并且我们不得不请翻译时，我都试着让他们
teach me how to say hello and how to say goodbye and I've written that in my diary and then when I see them I have I have used the hello and goodbye I wish it stayed in my head after we stopped work because I would know loads of different um different languages for hello and goodbye but it doesn't like look at what's on this child's name it's just it's just gone but it matters doesn't it in that moment when you're trying to forge relationships and you're trying to make somebody feel really, really safe to share, you know, really harrowing times in their lives. It really is important. It's a form of connection. It's a form of being seen, isn't it? It's a sense that actually this person in front of me has enough respect to see a version of me that is important to me and I think that's that's the bit that I
教我如何说你好和再见，我把这些写在我的日记里，然后当我见到他们时，我就用了这些你好和再见。我希望在我们停止工作后它们能留在我的脑海里，因为那样我就能知道很多不同语言的你好和再见了，但它没有。就像看看这个孩子的名字，它只是，它只是消失了。但在那一刻，当你试图建立关系，试图让某人感到非常、非常安全以至于愿意分享他们生活中真正令人痛苦的时刻时，这很重要，不是吗？这真的很重要。这是一种联系的形式。这是一种被看见的形式，不是吗？这是一种感觉，实际上我面前的这个人有足够的尊重来看到对我来说很重要的我的一个版本，我认为这就是我
think can help really make a therapist um you know develop that bond with somebody that they're seeing to actually show that person that I see all of you and even though this part might be a tiny tiny part I recognize that this is really really important for you this goes for supervisors this goes for everybody really working with another person. It's just an effective form of communication, I think. It's basic respect. It's basic respect as well. It's making me just so fondly reflect on some of the clients I have worked with across the years West stuff, sometimes what I'm able to give them as a as a Western woman is to be compassionate, to be seen, to be heard in a way that's really, really de-shaming. or in different situations abroad to then come here and kind of get my western perspective on
认为可以真正帮助治疗师，你知道，与他们所见的人建立那种联系，真正向那个人展示我看到了你的全部，即使这部分可能只是非常非常小的一部分，我也认识到这对你来说真的非常非常重要。这适用于主管，这适用于所有真正与他人一起工作的人。我认为这是一种有效的沟通形式。这也是基本的尊重。这也是基本的尊重。这让我非常深情地回顾了多年来我合作过的一些客户。有时，作为一名西方女性，我能给予他们的是同情心，让他们被看见、被倾听，这真的、真的能消除羞耻感。或者在国外的不同情况下，然后来到这里，以某种方式获得我的西方视角，
that to help them be more compassionate and realize it's not their fault it's really really powerful I'm not suggesting that west is best at all but sometimes I think it's more expected or or just kind of brushed under the carpet in in certain cultures and not even even nationally here in the UK as well but sometimes having someone just draw attention to that wasn't okay that happened to you that must have been really really challenging can be so liberating for people I think that's huge that's a really important part of that therapeutic space isn't it and I think that in itself can cause a block for people coming because there can be I suppose there has to be some way when you're not in that therapeutic
来帮助他们更有同情心，并意识到这不是他们的错。这真的非常非常强大。我根本不是在暗示西方就是最好的，但有时我认为在某些文化中，这更被期待，或者只是被掩盖了，甚至在英国国内也是如此。但有时让某人指出“那是不对的，发生在你身上的事一定非常非常具有挑战性”，这对人们来说可能是非常解放的。我认为这很重要，这是治疗空间中非常重要的一部分，不是吗？我认为这本身可能会给前来治疗的人造成障碍，因为我认为，当你不在那个治疗空间时，必须有某种方式
space there has to be some way to make sense of what you've experienced and so you know in a lot of South Asian cultures I don't know if you've seen it on social media there are so many memes there are so many reels on how you know the discipline was quite severe but somehow they've made it into a comical experience um and sharing that with friends like I used to get hit with this or I used to get hit with that and I think that that that is a way of making sense of the difficulties and the harsh discipline that a lot of people um experience growing up it's not just South Asian culture you know this is quite prevalent i think for a lot of people when they're growing up so then to think about actually do i need therapy for that because yeah i know i'm a bit snappy i know i've got a bit of an anger issue
来理解你所经历的事情。所以，你知道，在许多南亚文化中，我不知道你是否在社交媒体上看到过，有很多表情包，有很多短视频，关于你知道纪律是如何相当严厉的，但不知何故他们把它变成了一种滑稽的经历。并与朋友分享，比如“我过去常被这样打”或“我过去常被那样打”，我认为这是一种理解困难和严厉纪律的方式，很多人在成长过程中都经历过。这不仅仅是南亚文化，你知道，我认为这对很多人在成长过程中来说是很普遍的。所以，然后去思考“实际上我需要为此接受治疗吗？因为是的，我知道我有点急躁，我知道我有点愤怒问题，
here i know that i i you know i'm short-tempered or whatever but do i need therapy for that no i'm okay because everyone else had this as well and that's a shared experience that i've got so that makes sense and i think so that way i think it causes a bit of a problem that actually people kind of latch on to the meaning that they make of their adversity and that prevents them from then going into this space that can feel quite alien like what would that feel like for someone initially to sit with someone who's saying gosh that's harsh how are you how do you feel and then to open up what that could potentially feel like that I think that's a really really hard transition to make so even to get to therapy is such a hard very hard transition for a lot of people yeah I agree and even today this morning I
在这里，我知道我，你知道，我脾气暴躁或者其他什么，但我需要为此接受治疗吗？不，我很好，因为其他人也有过这种经历，这是我拥有的共同经历，所以这说得通。我认为，通过这种方式，我认为这造成了一点问题，实际上人们倾向于抓住他们从逆境中得出的意义，这阻止了他们进入这个可能感觉相当陌生的空间。对于一个最初坐在某人面前，听到对方说“天哪，那太严厉了，你怎么样，你感觉如何”，然后敞开心扉，那可能会是什么感觉？我认为这是一个非常非常难的转变。所以即使是去接受治疗，对很多人来说也是一个非常非常难的转变。是的，我同意，即使是今天，今天早上我
was having a chat with someone and you know I'm not the sort of clinician that's gonna chat to you on the phone and then book you in my diary I was like you need to have a go away have a think think about whether you feel this is going to be a good fit for you and there's no timeline on this you know entering therapy is such an important decision and I hope it will be life-changing for you so I really want to make sure that you're comfortable with this decision and that you feel that now is the right time. Because sometimes clients just want to put a toe in the water, make contact and then run away for a good six months, you know, because it's just not quite now. It's just not they're not quite ready. Yeah. Yeah. No, absolutely. I agree completely. I mean, it's making me think about an experience I did a call out on my social media because I do intensive work and I thought I had like three
在和某人聊天，你知道，我不是那种会在电话里和你聊天然后就把你记在日记里的临床医生。我说的是“你需要离开，去思考一下，考虑一下你是否觉得这适合你”，而且这没有时间限制。你知道，进入治疗是一个非常重要的决定，我希望它能改变你的生活，所以我真的想确保你对这个决定感到舒服，并且你觉得现在是合适的时机。因为有时客户只是想试水，建立联系，然后跑掉六个月，你知道，因为现在还不是时候。只是他们还没有准备好。是的。是的。不，绝对，我完全同意。我的意思是，这让我想起了一次经历，我在社交媒体上发出了呼吁，因为我做强化工作，我以为我有三个
slots I wondered if you know anybody would want to do and had so many inquiries had so many people interested but then to actually book that in to kind of sign up to that there was a real real drop-off because of that commitment you know it's so hard to actually kind of go and do the work so a part of that is actually building yourself up prior to getting on with the process not just jumping into that process and actually thinking about obviously the people listening to this and the journey that they're on that in itself is building them up isn't it for to get ready to go on to the clinical psychology doctorate all of that learning all of that preparing listening to podcasts like this
名额，我想知道是否有人想做，收到了很多询问，很多人感兴趣，但要真正预订它，要真正报名参加，因为那种承诺，真的有很多人流失了。你知道，真正去完成这项工作是如此困难。所以，这其中的一部分实际上是在开始这个过程之前先建立起自己，而不是直接跳进那个过程中。实际上，考虑到显然正在听这个节目的人以及他们正在经历的旅程，这本身就是在建立他们，不是吗？为了准备进入临床心理学博士课程，所有的学习，所有的准备，听像这样的播客，
listening to to more people talk about their own experiences I think that builds up some sense of I don't really particularly like the word resilience but there is an element of that there because I do think it's a tough process to go through and I think you have to kind of really be very strong and firm in who you are and the why like why are you doing it before you even start that doctorate because that brings with it a whole different kettle of fish doesn't it it does and you know the I think resilience was a word that came up time and time again in the aspiring psychologist collective um and for me it's almost can be a little bit damaging because sometimes there can be a tendency to use resilience resilience just a bit like a sponge to soak up really loads of
听更多的人谈论他们自己的经历，我认为这建立了一种……我不太喜欢“韧性”这个词，但其中确实有这种成分，因为我确实认为这是一个艰难的过程。我认为在开始博士课程之前，你必须真正非常坚定和稳固地了解你是谁以及为什么，因为这带来了完全不同的一堆麻烦，不是吗？确实，而且你知道，我认为“韧性”这个词在“有抱负的心理学家集体”中一次又一次地出现。对我来说，它几乎可能有点破坏性，因为有时人们倾向于把韧性当作一块海绵，用来吸收来自人们的真正大量的
rubbish treatment from people and I guess that's not what I mean and I know that's not what you mean either it's about just keeping the goal in mind. And because it took me three times to get on the clinical doctorate. And it's not just clinical psychologists or aspiring ones who listen to this. It kind of tries to be inclusive, but probably most people are looking at clinical. But for me, if I quit after my second attempt, then I wouldn't now be a clinical psychologist so there's something around that tenacity and resilience and determinism that has got me to where I am and of course maybe there's something about me that but of course my own privilege that's allowed me to be supported
垃圾对待。我想那不是我的意思，我知道那也不是你的意思。这只是关于牢记目标。因为我花了三次才进入临床博士课程。而且不仅仅是临床心理学家或有抱负的心理学家在听这个节目。它试图具有包容性，但可能大多数人都在关注临床。但对我来说，如果我在第二次尝试后就放弃了，那么我现在就不会是一名临床心理学家了。所以这其中有一些关于坚韧、韧性和决心的事情，让我走到了今天。当然，也许我身上有一些东西，但当然还有我自己的特权，这让我能够得到支持，
well enough just about well enough in some cases to get me there to feel safe enough to have food on the table and you know so there's absolutely conversations to be had around that as well but you do you know for the most part need to be able to keep going and keep going in a way where you don't know when there will be the finish line you imagine or hope for so hard it's bringing it back to me it's a long process as well it's almost like a year isn't it I think the whole churn of it but it is a very hard process and but that's what I think what I mean every time you go through it I think you you keep coming back to the why like why am I doing this what's the point
足够好，在某些情况下刚好足够好，让我走到这一步，让我感到足够安全，有饭吃。所以，关于这一点绝对有对话的空间。但你确实，你知道，在大多数情况下，你需要能够坚持下去，并且以一种你不知道终点线会在什么时候的方式坚持下去，你想象或希望得太辛苦了。这让我想起了，这也是一个漫长的过程。这几乎像是一年，不是吗？我认为整个过程，但这确实是一个非常艰难的过程。但这就是我认为我的意思，每次你经历它时，我认为你都会不断回到“为什么”——我为什么要这样做？意义何在？
can I do this can I keep going on and that in itself is a learning process because you keep growing with it, you know, I think it's, I've known people who have tried, I think I met an assistant once who was on her eighth go, you know, she just wasn't stopping and she got on, you eventually, I think the system ends up working for you some way or another as long as you keep learning with it that's the most important part isn't it to just keep learning and growing with it rather than internalizing it trying to think it's something about you making it about actually how you're a failure and all of those negative thoughts try and step away from that I think that's so massively important and just remind yourself this is a big system and you know eventually you just
我能做到吗？我能坚持下去吗？这本身就是一个学习过程，因为你不断地随之成长。你知道，我认为，我认识一些尝试过的人，我想我曾经遇到过一位助理，她已经是第八次尝试了，你知道，她就是没有停止，她最终成功了。我认为系统最终会以某种方式为你工作，只要你不断地随之学习。这是最重要的部分，不是吗？只是不断学习和成长，而不是内化它，试图认为这是关于你自己的，认为你是一个失败者，所有那些消极的想法，试着远离它。我认为这非常非常重要，只要提醒自己这是一个庞大的系统，你知道，最终你只需要
need to find your way to work it yeah absolutely and certainly the advice I would give is don't use your form from last year because you know you know I love the way you said churn it does feel like a churn like oh here we go again um in the space of a year you should have changed like so much since you last wrote that form um and so don't look at it like look at last year's until you know you're maybe a few weeks away from submitting in case you've missed a golden nugget that you did put in last year but for me I would say always start again because you're you know you're living a different life and even if you're in the same role you should be thinking differently about
找到适合你的方法。是的，绝对。当然，我会给出的建议是：不要使用你去年的表格，因为你知道，我知道我喜欢你说“搅动”的方式，它确实感觉像是一种搅动，就像“哦，又来了”。在一年之内，你应该已经改变了很多，自从你上次写那份表格以来。所以不要看着它，不要看去年的，直到你知道你可能离提交还有几周的时间，以防你错过了去年你写进去的“金块”。但对我来说，我会说总是重新开始，因为你，你知道，你正在过着不同的生活，即使你在同一个职位上，你也应该以不同的方式思考
the work you're doing in the space of a year absolutely keep learning keep growing keep talking to people about their experiences keep asking questions that's the process it's just you are like a sponge because you just want to absorb everything to keep checking whether it's what you want to do to keep learning about the different areas of psychology that exist and the different ways of working and if you feel like you're hitting that wall then that's the point isn't it to step back and kind of reassess and maybe take a different step or a different action forward but keep learning so so important we don't stop learning and it's kind of coming back to the earlier point that we said that's the benefit of cpd cpd that's the benefit of talking to people with networking liaising you just learn
你正在做的工作。在一年之内，绝对要保持学习，保持成长，保持与人们谈论他们的经历，保持提问，这就是过程。你就像一块海绵，因为你只是想吸收一切，以不断检查这是否是你想要做的事情，以不断了解存在的不同心理学领域和不同的工作方式。如果你觉得你撞到了那堵墙，那么这就是重点，不是吗？退后一步，重新评估，也许采取不同的步骤或不同的行动向前迈进。但要保持学习，这非常非常重要。我们不会停止学习，这有点回到我们之前提到的观点，这就是CPD（持续专业发展）的好处。CPD，这就是与人交谈、建立网络、联络的好处，你只是学到了
so much about how we can help people differently i think that's the great opportunity of this work it really is we've got our placards but this is what i want for people so whoever whoever they are, whoever, whatever discipline they want to go in, even if it doesn't end up being a professionally qualified psychology discipline, I want them to love what they're doing and where they're at and to know that that's possible. That's key. That's key. I think people coming into this profession have core values, don't they, of compassion, of kindness and wanting to connect with people and that's always got to feel good I think that's always got to be a guiding force for them so I agree I think it's just about keep doing what feels good keep doing what feels right it's not
这么多关于我们如何以不同方式帮助人们的知识。我认为这是这项工作的巨大机会。确实是这样。我们有我们的标语，但这正是我想要为人们做的。所以无论他们是谁，无论他们想要进入什么学科，即使最终不是一个专业合格的心理学学科，我也希望他们热爱他们正在做的事情和他们所处的位置，并知道这是可能的。这是关键。这是关键。我认为进入这个行业的人有核心价值观，不是吗？同情心、善良以及想要与人建立联系，这必须始终感觉良好。我认为这必须始终是他们的指导力量。所以我同意，我认为这只是关于坚持做感觉良好的事情，坚持做感觉正确的事情。这并不是
always going to be a great easy experience as you all know but I think as long as you can keep checking in with whether it's in line with your values with where you're at that's the most important thing I love that and I feel like honestly I could talk to you all day um but time is slightly limited because of the podcast could you give us maybe your top tip for reducing burnout um for aspiring psychologists if that's okay oh gosh top tip I for me it always comes down to what I just said there with your values and being really connected to your current sense of identity and who you are and where you're at and I think a lot of people overstep that so we're so busy in our lives we're so busy with the doing and the trying to reach the place that we think we should be at, that we don't often pause enough with where we're at and reflect enough on that process and how that feels for us.
总是会是一次伟大而轻松的经历，正如你们所知，但我认为只要你能不断检查它是否符合你的价值观，是否符合你所处的位置，这就是最重要的事情。我喜欢这一点，老实说，我觉得我可以和你聊一整天，但由于播客的原因，时间有点有限。你能给我们一些关于减少倦怠的顶级建议吗？对于有抱负的心理学家，如果可以的话。哦，天哪，顶级建议。对我来说，它总是归结为我刚才所说的关于你的价值观，以及与你当前的身份感、你是谁以及你所处的位置真正保持联系。我认为很多人越过了这一点。所以我们在生活中太忙了，我们太忙于做事，太忙于试图达到我们认为我们应该达到的位置，以至于我们没有经常停下来思考我们所处的位置，也没有对那个过程以及这对我们意味着什么进行足够的反思。
So doing a lot more of that, really sitting with and really, really thinking about like, where am I feeling internally? What are my values? And what is happening around me to connect me to those values? Or what is pulling me away from those values and what can I do to help myself feel more balanced with that I think that's so so crucial so a lot of just the sitting with the reflecting and just kind of encompassing all of that within compassion because regardless of where you're at there are going to be challenges and if you can start to develop that compassionate voice within yourself I think that's going to be challenges and if you can start to develop that compassionate voice within yourself I think that's going to be one of the most important and most powerful tools
所以多做一些反思，真正坐下来，真正地、真正地思考：我在内心深处感觉如何？我的价值观是什么？周围发生了什么让我与这些价值观联系起来？或者是什么在把我从这些价值观中拉开？我能做些什么来帮助自己在这方面感到更平衡？我认为这非常非常关键。所以，很多只是坐下来反思，并以同情心包容这一切。因为无论你处于什么位置，都会有挑战。如果你能开始在内心培养那种富有同情心的声音，我认为这将是挑战。如果你能开始在内心培养那种富有同情心的声音，我认为这将是
you will take forward and I remember you saying actually Marianne I listened to one of your earlier podcasts I'd be interested to know if this statistic has changed but you said the self-compassion one was the one that was downloaded the least and I find that so interesting because that's the problem we tend to overstep the stuff that's going to help us so really really do think about actually what are you doing to tool yourself up in a very kind way that connects you to your values really important um the yeah the compassion I think was one of the least three downloaded episodes so what I will do is I will seamlessly look at the um look at the stats and then when I do the outro for this I will give people the answer to that little riddle
你将带向未来的最重要、最强大的工具之一。我记得你确实说过，玛丽安，我听了你早期的播客之一，我很想知道这个统计数据是否发生了变化，但你说关于“自我同情”的那一集是下载量最少的一集。我觉得这太有趣了，因为这就是问题所在，我们倾向于越过那些能帮助我们的东西。所以真的、真的要考虑一下，实际上你正在做什么来以一种非常友善的方式武装自己，让你与你的价值观联系起来，这非常重要。嗯，是的，同情心，我认为是下载量最少的三集之一。所以我将要做的是，我将无缝地查看统计数据，然后在做这一集的结尾时，我会给人们那个小谜语的答案。
but yeah thank you thank you for highlighting it's so important isn't it and it's for me it was the difference that made the difference and I wish I'd picked up literature on self-compassion whilst I was an aspiring psychologist um because I didn't discover it until I wasion whilst I was an aspiring psychologist because I didn't discover it until I was qualified until I was a mother of two until my dad had died in 2008 I think it was and so you know just think about what a gentle journey I could have had on myself had I had self-compassion in my world that's perfect because it's a journey either way isn't it so is it going to be a brutal harsh one or is it one is it going to be one that actually can be quite compassionate with yourself about and actually just nurture yourself through because you will
但是的，谢谢你，谢谢你强调这一点。这非常重要，不是吗？对我来说，这就是带来改变的改变。我希望我在成为有抱负的心理学家时就能读到关于自我同情的文献，因为我直到我获得资格，直到我成为两个孩子的母亲，直到我父亲在2008年去世（我想是那一年）之后才发现它。所以，你知道，只要想想如果我的世界里有自我同情，我本可以拥有多么温柔的旅程。这很完美，因为无论如何这都是一段旅程，不是吗？所以它会是一段残酷、严厉的旅程，还是你可以对自己相当有同情心，并且实际上只是在其中滋养自己的旅程？因为你无论如何都会
be growing and learning either way so I suppose it's that choice point that Ross Harris talks about and it's just deciding which way am I going to tackle this and how am I going to get myself through this because you will get through it one way or another you will thank you so much for your kind words and your thoughtfulness and your time today in helping us learn more about about you and the way you see the world and your culture and your religion as well oh thank you so much Marion you're really easy to talk to and I love what you're doing here so absolutely if anyone has any questions just touch base reach out but no thank you for inviting me along oh and we haven't done the where can people connect with you so we should definitely do that where can people hang out and and meet you and get to know more about you and your work i'm so sorry about that no no that's fine i'm on social media um at dr core therapy
成长和学习。所以我认为这就是罗斯·哈里斯谈到的那个选择点，这只是决定我将以哪种方式来应对这个问题，以及我将如何让自己度过难关。因为你无论如何都会度过难关的，你会的。非常感谢你的善意、你的体贴以及你今天的时间，帮助我们更多地了解你，以及你看待世界的方式，还有你的文化和宗教。哦，非常感谢你，玛丽安，和你交谈真的很轻松，我喜欢你在这里所做的事情。所以绝对的，如果任何人有任何问题，请联系我，伸出援手。但不，谢谢你邀请我来。哦，我们还没有做“人们可以在哪里与你联系”，所以我们绝对应该做那个。人们可以在哪里闲逛、见到你并更多地了解你和你的工作？我很抱歉。不，不，没关系。我在社交媒体上，在 @dr core therapy
so if you can you can access me uh instagram tiktok linkedin facebook at doctor core therapy lovely and for anyone who is not watching that on youtube that is k-a-u-r so doctor is d-r and then k-a-u-r therapy and that's that's you across all of your platforms is it oh yeah that's it love it a bit of consistency thank you again for your time and let me know if I can help with anything in future but it's a pleasure to speak to you in person too thank you thank you welcome back along what an incredible conversation and what a pleasure it was to speak to Dr Gurpreet Kaur I hope you found it a really interesting list and in answer to the question about the compassion episode it is episode number four so it was way back there in the early days it has since increased its popularity it is now up there with um in the top three pages of downloads um but there are 10 pages so it's still only on page three so
所以如果你可以，你可以访问我，Instagram、TikTok、LinkedIn、Facebook，在 @doctor core therapy。可爱。对于任何没有在YouTube上观看的人，那是 K-A-U-R。所以 doctor 是 D-R，然后是 K-A-U-R therapy。这就是你在所有平台上的名字，是吗？哦，是的，就是这样。喜欢它，有一点一致性。再次感谢你的时间，如果将来我能帮上什么忙，请告诉我。但亲自和你交谈也很荣幸。谢谢你，谢谢你。欢迎回来。多么令人难以置信的对话，与 Gurpreet Kaur 博士交谈真是太荣幸了。我希望你觉得这是一个非常有趣的列表。关于同情心那一集的问题，它是第四集，所以它是在早期的日子里。它此后增加了受欢迎程度，它现在在下载量的前三页中，但有10页，所以它仍然只在第三页，所以
they absolutely could do with a little bit more airtime, I think, for sure. But yes, not doing as badly as it was. So maybe me saying it was one of the least downloaded episodes has helped people. Please do remember that the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book are really, really useful companions for you. Whatever stage of your career you're at there are links in my descriptions for both of those if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes please do let me know and if you'd welcome some more advice support guidance do consider the aspiring psychologist membership which you can join from just 30 pounds a month and there's loads of great stuff in there about completing your form about reflecting about cbt about formulation and so many other useful
它们绝对需要多一点的播出时间，我想，肯定的。但是是的，没有像以前那么糟糕了。所以也许我说它是下载量最少的剧集之一确实帮助了人们。请记住，《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书对你来说是非常非常有用的伴侣。无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，我的描述中都有这两本书的链接。如果你对未来的播客剧集有任何想法，请告诉我。如果你欢迎更多的建议、支持和指导，请考虑“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”，你可以每月仅需30英镑加入，里面有很多关于完成表格、反思、CBT、构思以及许多其他有用的好东西。
bits thank you so much for listening if you are watching on youtube like i said please do subscribe please do drop me a comment i will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which will be available to you from monday 6 a.m thank you so much for being part of my world and be kind to yourselves take care if you're looking to become a psychologist Thank you. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become
谢谢你的收听。如果你正在YouTube上观看，正如我所说，请订阅，请给我留言。我期待着在下一集《有抱负的心理学家播客》中与你见面，该播客将于周一早上6点提供给你。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请善待自己，保重。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，谢谢。这是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫 Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为
a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一名临床心理学家，这真的很有趣。这让我感到惊讶，有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有成为一名心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到轻松，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。